معنا من جنين مراسل الجزيره ليث جعار ليث
تقف حيث استشهدت الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله
ويظهر اثار التخريب والتجريف الذي قام به
عناصر من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهي
ليست المره الاولى التي تقوم بها قوات
الاحتلال بذلك صف لنا المشهد حيث
انت نعم حاله من الدمار الواسعه في هذه
المنطقه على وقع العمليات العسكريه لجيش
الاحتلال والاقتحامات المتواصله لمدينه
ومخيم جنين حيث نتواجد في هذه او في هذا
المكان تحديدا مكان استشهاد الزميله شيرين
ابو عاقله حيث قام الاحتلال بتجريف
المنطقه بالكامل وتدمير النصب التذكاري
لها في هذه في هذا الطريق ضمن سياسه
الاحتلال المتواصله
لاستهداف تحديدا هذه المنطقه بالتجريف
المتواصل ايه و في كل اقتحام له لهذه
المنطقه انسحب الاحتلال بشكل كامل من
مدينه جنين بعد عمليه عسكريه استمرت لثلاث
ساعات في المنطقه الشرقيه والمنطقه
الصناعيه داهم عده احياء وعده منازل تم
خلالها اعتقال عدد من الفلسطينيين فيما
داهم ودمر وخرب عدد من المنازل والمحال
التجاريه ايضا في المنطقه الشرقيه خلال
هذه العمليه العسكريه قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت احد المنازل صادرت اموال بما لا
يقل عن 40,000 شيقل وايضا نتحدث عن مصاغ ل
احد المواطنين تم يعني سحبه ومصادرته ب
بدون اي مبرر كما تحدث لنا اصحاب هذه
المنازل قوات الاحتلال داهمت عده احياء من
المدينه تحديدا تركزت في المنطقه الشرقيه
وايضا المنطقه الصناعيه ايه امس ايضا كان
هنا في هذا المكان تدمير للبنى التحتيه
وللصبر كاري
للزميلات
الاحتلال حمله مداهمات واسعه في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله تركزت في مدينه قلقيليه
حيث اقتحم عدد من المنازل ونفذ خلالها
حمله مداهمات واسعه والتخريب لممتلكات
الفلسطينيين ايه في مدينه طول كرم تحديدا
في بلده عنبت حيث اقتحم الاحتلال ايه ال
بلده واعتقل فلسطينيين اثنين بعد مداهمه
منزلهم والعبث بمحتويات هذه المنازل في
مدينه رام الله والبيره ايضا كان هناك
اقتحام لجيش الاحتلال ومداهم ايضا لمنازل
وكذلك في مدن جنوب الضفا الغربيه المحتله
من منطقه الخليل وايضا بيت لحم ومخيم عقبه
جبر في ساعات الصباح الاولى الذي اقتحمه
الاحتلال بعدد من الاليات العسكريه ومن ثم
انسحب على الفور هنا ميدانيا في جنين لا
تزال الاقتحامات
متواصله في كل يوم للمدينه وتحديدا لمخيم
جنين الذي يشهد منذ السابع من اكتوبر
حمله يعني حمله تتصاعد في وتيرتها التدمير
والتخريب لممتلكات الفلسطينيين للبنى
التحتيه من شبكات الصرف الصحي شبكات
المياه وايضا الكهرباء بالتزامن مع
استمرار الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غ ز
وليث اثر كل عمليه اقتحام وممارسات قوات
الاحتلال في الاما الاماكن التي تقتحمها
تحدث اشتباكات مع مقاومين
فلسطينيين نعم نعم الاشتباكات تحديدا هذه
الليله جرت في عده احياء من المنطقه
الشرقيه اثناء اقتحام الاحتلال ومحاصر بعض
المناطق في الاحياء الشرقيه نصب الاحتلال
القناص الاسرائيليه جرت اشتباكات مسلحه
بين الفينه والاخرى مع المقاومين
الفلسطينيين حتى انسحاب الاحتلال اثناء
انسحاب الاليات كان هناك اشتباك مسلح عنيف
استهدف هذه الاليات العسكريه عند الطريق
او عند في طريق شارع الناصره الواصل الى
حاجز الجلمه الذي يربط شمال الضفا الغربيه
المحتله بالداخل المحتل شكرا جزيلا لك من
جنين مراد الجزيره ليث جعر